e aí galera e garanti meu canal tudo não
gozei como está tudo ótimo como sempre
agora vou fazer a canon e do meu próprio
vídeo que sou eu me propagandinha gente
a sessão de stand up de são paulo está
esgotado esgotou em deus 800 lugares
todinho meio porém abriu segunda sessão
já vendeu um pouco da segunda sessão mas
ainda tem greve para a segunda sessão em
são paulo vai falar para comprar o
ingresso rápido ponto com ponto b é o
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo é só
clicar nele já vai direto no lugar de
compreender essa galera é ela está
fazendo um vídeo respondendo pergunta né
eu quero ver me perguntar a uma pergunta
que eu achei muito interessante
relembrar o passado o cara perguntou pra
mim assim o estratega vontade de ser
[ __ ] jacques enviado já que cheguei eu
lembrei de um acontecimento da minha
vida e eu queria compartilhar aqui pra
você eu sempre foi uma criança muda nada
vou dizer que você foi a criança muda
nada sempre uma pessoa muito inteligente
também foi montar tudo pra fazer as
coisas e esperar minha mãe dormir vai
subir em cima de três cadeira para
chegar em cima da estante para pegar o
leite nem para poder comer leite mim por
pouco eu conseguia fazer o plano
perfeito negócio é que o leite e
entregava porquê porque quando a gente
bota mundo a colher muito grande leite
na boca ele a pega no céu na boca aí das
duas uma ou você não fala ou então você
corre algum lugar entre um desastre e um
dia me pegou e pegou estava lá na na
cozinha com o mesmo leite naquela chegou
se um está com menos leite em pó
escondido vocês só porque tem aquele
leite chamado leite não foi à fábrica de
leite em pó tentando ajudar as crianças
eles quer que as crianças consumo mesmo
leite em pó então eles colocaram o nome
do leite leite não porque quando a mãe
fala assim o assunto tá combinado leite
em pó a única qualquer criança consegue
falar com a boca cheia de leite em pó
não tá com medo e leite em pó
é né a boca cheia de leite em pó e eu
era uma criança muda nada nesse tempo
está passando aquele filme tropa de
elite acaba de lançar o filme tropa de
elite está ligado tropa de elite e
capitão nascimento não é sobre ninguém
tá no sangue maior destruição eu queria
muito assistir a esse filme só que minha
mãe deixar porque eu era uma criança
ainda é não deixar o chelsea outro ponto
que pode assistir a esse filme um dia
fui dormir na casa de um amigo meu e
meia cada amigo meu a mãe do amigo meu é
igual à minha mãe não deixava assistindo
também não tinha como aí foi conseguir o
que aconteceu como eu estava passando o
dia na cabeça mente por três dia a mãe
dele saiu e equipar a escola né fiquei
lá sozinha com a criança como é danada
eu era muito nada maligno foi olhar um
dvd que tinha lá né não
achei aquela dvd tropa de elite
destruindo por trás da fala empurra a
tropa que o dvd tá que o tropa de elite
direito né
botei o dvd sentei esperando ver fãs
destruição e morte é a única coisa que
eu vi gente instituição de culpa que
quando começou a passar o filme gente
eram os caras vestir de capitão
nascimento no outro
aí eu peguei muita gente eu tomei um
trauma aí eu falei corra já estamos aqui
né
abriu a porta por aí e wilson não gostar
papai eu fiquei meu deus aquela nojeira
que dá na criança quando desce com neném
que toma vai lá e pega vai pôr trás vai
gente eu comecei a me empolgar assistir
a um filme e eu fui assistir falar estou
aqui assistir pocharschi 15 minutos
porque não se chega 30 chegando aos 30
minutos após a 60 minutos que a nossa
história de segundas escolhas em uma
besta quadrada mesmo assim mesmo tipo na
uti assistir 45 minutos não assisti todo
assistir todo filme todo dia sem querer
eu assisti ouviu de um hora e meia aí eu
fiquei meu deus que é refletir né
nunca tive vontade de beijar o rapaz
nunca tinha votado nela
depois que assisti àquele filme fiquei
um dia o pai tocava passar uma hora
tornando-o outro no mínimo alguma coisa
de boa tem isso aí um dia eu fui tomar
banho é tarde botão banho e sabão ano
passei a mão na minha bunda
achei legal nef passa mais mais mas foi
naquela carenciada né meu dedo falei pai
fora só está aí eu fui a unha é pá toma
nem acontecer nada com meu estava pelo
lado de dentro a tolice de todos aqui
dentro do google
aí eu coloquei aqui pensa que é grande
maré um mesmo e aí eu tentei botar no
seco assim mesmo empurrando mas não foi
mais fácil do ema não não eu pensei não
vou botar o robô taxam culto que eu
pensei não se xampu já no olho da cara
imagina o documento botar custo e botei
o spinning e coloquei negro minuta
fiquei refletindo o que eu tinha feito
com dependendo só que aí o que me salvou
de ser [ __ ] foi porque diz depois disso
eu perdi minha virgindade da frente aí
falei não realmente é muito melhor que a
higiene do sono como eu gostei mais de
de furado que servirá como dia que ela
fala da virgindade é igual água mole em
pedra dura tanto bate até que fura eu
gostei foi da foragida
não furei aí falei não então realmente
assim né pra mim eu tinha um tio que é
policial era pra se aparecer lá em casa
ele viu muito jogar com strike nerds
policiai aduto quer ser policial também
de não identificar não um negócio embora
nem mesmo essas quotas que encontramos é
mesmo podia ver uma viatura da polícia
militar o local já é assim quando o trio
é isso aí eu quero que você me conte
aqui em baixo alguma coisa que já
aconteceu com você quando você era
criança sobre esse negócio de descobrir
a masturbação descobrir a perder a
virgindade é que você comece aqui
embaixo e não esquece que ela é de são
paulo para comprar o ingresso do show no
dia 18 agora é
na descrição do vídeo deixar o seu
líquidos em que vai gostar né ajuda
demais
muito obrigado um beijão valeu e é nóis